I'm the youngest leader in my firm's
history I try and implement extreme
ownership and default aggressiveness in
my team being so young some of my elder
subordinates sometimes dismiss my
directives how do I leave this
effectively okay so I actually hate when
I get this question or questions like
this because it means that I've screwed
up that's what he hates I don't like to
screw up but when I see a question like
this it means that somebody has
misinterpreted the message a little bit
they haven't read the dichotomy
leadership for sure and in my opinion
because if you read the dichotomy
leadership you'll see that extreme
ownership and default aggressive are
supposed to be balanced mm-hmm and so
that's what's going on here you got
someone that's like you know what I'm
going to take extreme ownership hey
we're doing this my way this is on the
boss I'm a leader and that's just
horrible and everyone hates you so bro
you're young they don't hate you because
you're young they're not mad at you
because you're an experienced they don't
dismiss you because because you are a
decade younger than that's not why it's
happening it's happening because you are
lacking humility you haven't built up
any relationship with these people you
haven't built up any leadership capital
with them you haven't asked them how
they think they should do things you
haven't asked them what they've been
doing for the last 22 years while you
were gonna middle school right so come
in be humble them the best way to gain
respect from people this is what's hard
to do this what's hard to understand you
want people to respect you ask them a
question
listen to what they have to say mm-hm
listen to their opinion they come up
with a good plan use their plan the
worst way to gain respect from people is
to go in and demand respect from people
is to go in and say I'm implementing
defaults to Chris if he not heard of
that you never read extreme ownership
have you I'll tell you what that's the
way we're dealing it here I'll get you a
copy so you can read up and get on board
with my program these are all bad so I'm
not trying to say you sound just like
that but you might sound something like
that and you don't need to be too far
off that so
appreciate that you're getting after it
but what you need to get after more is
some balance be humble listen to the
team listen to what they have to say ask
for their input follow very important
that's a little black belt move it's a
little black belt it's actually a blue
belt move but blue belt purple belt move
like hey my team gives me input I listen
to them mmm we actually you know hey
echo how do you think which I think we
should attack this target from the north
okay sounds good why don't we roll with
that that's a Bluebell move man what's
it what's a white belt move negative no
the white belt moves like hey echo we're
doing this were attacking his target
from the south
I'm not got any questions and you're
like well I think I could didn't from
the north might be a little bit better
that might be what you think but that's
not what we're doing
plus I'm in charge because I got
ownership of this whole thing and I'm
default aggressive so do what I said
so don't be that guy man try and back
off a little bit try and phone dude has
a leader you should be looking at like
you're one of your primary goals primary
goal is to form a relationship with your
team with the people in her team so get
it done
I remember in jujitsu one time Craig
McIntyre great Gregory yes he he he was
teaching the move and the move that he
was teaching he apparently got from me
and so he was teaching this move or
whatever and you know I sit in their
world and he was TV Tatia Tatia Tatia
good thought it way better than I could
teach yeah way better
in fact he taught it I simply probably
could not teach this move in here and
after he was done he was like hey echo
does his move really good to the class I
could I could do you have anything to
add to them it was like I know I don't I
don't remember if I did I don't think I
did but just that feeling you know he
included me and if you know a man and it
was so empowering you know you know it
was you know any in his minor and I
actually thinking back and in my mind
like that it that was kind of my move
you know yeah what move was it was it
was a card pass move yeah the one I
always do to you mmm
haha oh yeah but nonetheless like just
how you say like how you asked their
input kind of thing it's like you
include them in the thing and that's not
just asking it it's actually receiving
it and implementing it that's the that's
the kick that's the closure of the move
man yeah that's the closure of the move
bro I talk about like a feeling and
granted me and Gregor good friends
anyway but I'm just saying like you can
imagine that situation how that how
anyone would feel when you especially if
you're older than this little young buck
who does he think he is and it comes to
you you're like all hell yeah okay this
guy knows like you know we can we can do
this together you know really get that
feeling I would imagine anyway that's
what you want to do mister youngest
leader in your firm's history
dang congrats on that yeah congrats on
your getting after it what got you there
may not get you to the next level what
got you there might have been like being
aggressive and making things happen and
steppin up that's cool but if you piss
off everyone in your department that's
not gonna work out good for you and
they'll start to undermine you they'll
sabotage you so you got to be careful I
mean okay is there a possibility that
everyone in the department you got put
in there to straighten things out that's
a different question that's a different
question let me tell you something else
when you're getting when people are
dismissing what you're saying that's a
horrible sign I'm one of the leadership
books that we covered the rule was don't
give commands that you that won't that
aren't going to be followed because
every time you give a command that that
you know isn't gonna be followed that's
not gonna work out good for you it's
reinforcing the fact that no one needs
to listen to you so don't don't be
giving orders that are being dismissed
if somebody doesn't do something you go
hey man I know that I might have come
across a little wrong when I was talking
to you about you know getting this done
this product just part of this task done
and I see it's still not done is there
is there some support that you need for
me is there some help that you need for
me because this is importantly I
probably do a good job of explaining why
it's important but it's actually
connected to this larger project that
we're doing over at headquarters and
this is our part of the task and I don't
think I explained that very well but do
you need anything else for me to to
maybe move this along
you can't just allow things to be for
you to talk to tree to give directions
and they just get blown off yeah like
that's not good wouldn't I
what I'm not saying is oh you blew off
my order now I'm gonna go high order on
you right that's not what I'm saying
yeah yeah that makes sense too cuz man
if I had a boss who I was I was primed
to dismiss any of his directives yeah
and it happened and it happened
successfully like it's missed it and
there was really no real repercussions
oh you better believe I'm picking and
choosing what I'm following by the way
that's not that he's testing the
envelope anyway she's testing to see you
know what he can get away with but cuz
he sees you're young young one in here
thing he's gonna tell me what to do
watch this yeah and listen to you okay
cool now if you fly off the handle and
go nuts you know what you'll get them to
do it immediately
yeah and then guess what you're gonna
get undermined usurped you're gonna get
they're gonna have the project failed
just so they can get rid of you they're
gonna laugh at you as the as you're
getting walked out by the HR department
so you got it careful man you got to be
careful that's what I'm saying
balance these things out balance extreme
ownership get the book dichotomy
leadership that's what it's about
it's about being balanced